foreign
Russ is with us in South Bend hi Russ
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks so much uh Dave we are a young
married couple in our early 70s and we
have we're financially free and at this
stage of Life we've got about eighty
thousand dollars in cash we've gone
through Financial Peace University and
uh designated the emergency fund out of
that but my question is twofold
um what's the best thing to do with that
money obviously sitting in the bank is
probably not the best thing to do the
second question is is the goal of wealth
realistic at this stage in our lives
uh we have to Define wealth uh extreme
wealth unless you make really really
good money no because time is not on
your side
um but uh but can we you know can we
build a nice Nest Egg a plump one sure
and of course that depends on a whole a
whole host of other factors from
variables that you can control some of
and some of you can affect but yeah
um so
but I mean sixty thousand invested in
good mutual funds if it averages 10
percent would double every seven years
so it'd be if you don't add anything to
it so it would be you know and you know
when if you're 70 it would when you're
77 it would be 120 and if you're
um 84 it'd be 240.
give or take but I mean that's pretty
close
and that's if you don't anything to it
now of course you've got income you've
got other things going on but you know a
quarter million dollars uh as a plump
little nest egg in your early 80s is
certainly better than a whole host of
people
absolutely and you know neighborhood I
grew up in we called that rich but it's
probably not really rich but yeah
well that's that's great so mutual funds
would be the way to go in your opinion
if you're going to leave your hands off
of it yeah if you can leave your hands
off of it you have an emergency fund in
addition and uh you have income to live
on
yeah we both uh we we pull in about 60
Grand a year uh about 30 a piece uh at
this stage I've got a financial stream
from my old Insurance business I live on
residuals and occasional referrals uh
she also is on Social Security and uh
she's working at an accounting firm and
she does a little part-time work for
that so this is semi retirement for us
and there is a street income streams for
both of us among that uh that amount of
money
good perfect excellent well done yeah I
mean so you're secure and uh and so we
can allow this money to grow we might
even be able to add a little bit to it
as we go along uh if you wanted to
there's there's no no Panic here it's
not like the the house is on fire but
you've done it good I mean you set
yourself up to where you should be able
to prosper with that